[Musique]
quel est votre nom déjà
espen feu follet
je voudrais que nous le faisions notre
verre et que notre un pion à la santé de
la princesse christie
[Musique]
comment ça s'est passé
le roi et la reine ont avalé le posant
[Rires]
il n'existe aucun antidote
pas si vite vous connaissez le palais de
soria moria il a été bâti autour de la
source de l'eau de la vie il faut
absolument trouver ce palais je me suis
fourré nous devons trouver le palais de
soria maria
comment as tu réussi à résister à ma
musique explique moi
l'eau de la vie vous vous souvenez
comment on y va
est ce qu'on va trouver la princesse où
on va la cie
nous allons pouvoir conquérir le monde
[Musique]
comment tu fais tu reste optimiste tout
le temps espen va ronger simple
[Musique]
quelle est la dernière chose dont tu te
souviens
banny nous est titulaire si tu as
survécu
c'est parce que tu n'es pas une jeune
fille ordinaire tu n'es plus seul
plus maintenant savez-vous ce gain de
temps l'un d'eux vous souhaite raconter
sa première fois où j'avais 13 ans je ne
maîtrisais plus rien j'en sais rien j'ai
paniqué il eu des blessés c'est ma
copine disent les pouilles les juifs il
y en a j'ai tué 18 personnes une par
pays
[Musique]
on n'est pas dans un hôpital on est en
cash
j'ai des quelque chose
un truc qu'elle voulait pas que je vois
je crois pas qu'on soit là pour acquérir
cet endroit fait ressurgir des plus
grandes peurs il te les faire vivre
jusqu'à ce qu'elle te tue on peut s'en
sortir
ensemble
[Musique]
tiens qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ma femme elle est vivante pas outre la
retient en otage quelque part mais là
tout de suite on est un peu dans la
merde tu te fout de notre gueule à tout
ça c'est un merdier infernale est en eux
les blaireaux les plus recherchés du
pays qu'on a un super terroriste
et de nouveaux super héros
salut je m'appelle ce tome forte c'est
moi la nouvelle maire
[Musique]
vas-y c'est quoi ton plan on va détruire
ma route il devait récupérer matin au
dessus évidemment conduit là où elle est
d'autres super terroriste suivront
mais qu'est ce qu'on en sait peut-être
que ces maniaques attendent la première
occasion de tous nous tuer [ __ ] pour
qui tu te prends
j'essaie simplement d'aider vraiment
comment on est en guerre
et on peut riposter avec une armée forte
de plusieurs millions de super héros
allez fais pas ta chochotte carbonise -
les saints est là toute une armée de
super il faut qu'on la tht et on fait
quoi maintenant on peut pas tuer tout le
monde
si c'est exactement ce qu'on va faire
c'est quoi ça
non génial kool savas la joue
il faut jusqu'au tiennent le coup
allez-y les gars je reste là c'est bon
tu lèves les mains tu fais un tour de
magie et tu vas tu
[Musique]
mais marquer
moody's
[Musique]
ok
c
[Musique]
alors
volonté
toi aussi
[Musique]
bien sûr
tagetik steyn
[Musique]
il n'aimait son habituel
il
des chinois tsui au fait
oui
m
oh mon dieu donne
cette voie là
alors tout
c
m
oui
les salades